meantime CCSD students will begin their
fourth week of school come Monday yet
there are still children who are not
properly enrolled and that's certainly a
big issue when it comes to Shared
housing yeah so that applies to families
who have a shared long-term living
Arrangement maybe like a blended family
or multi-generational Family Madison
Timber
Aaron's today and she joins us now live
with an update
yeah this is where families can go who
do shared housing to enroll their
children this is different from previous
where recently the district changed how
it enrolls its students individual
schools used to approve it now it is the
district and specific documents need to
be notarized
my kids are starting Monday so they
haven't started school yet because we
had to get to pay get it notarized and
stuff like that Philip Cole does shared
housing and says because of the new
regulations in place it's been hard for
his son to get enrolled the drive up
here was all we had to do
um now we have to go deal with the
school so it's like shared housing then
you have to deal with the school but
that's it it's it's a process that
shouldn't have to happen but we have to
do what we have to do groups such as the
National Action Network calling out CCSD
for the lack of students in class this
year stating that it's their new
enrollment policy keeping these kids
behind and that the school district
should lift requirements but in a letter
sent in response to the network CCSD
responding stating that the new shared
housing process was done to align with
school assignment changes and that there
is no truth to the claim that 10 000
students are not attending class while
CCSD says they've contacted families mom
Heather is left frustrated went over
their lines wrapped around the entire
building all the way through the parking
lot uh went home called every hour on
the hour
and it was like that for about two weeks
my phone call finally went through to
them where somebody actually picked up
the phone and gave me information two
days ago
CCSD States throughout the summer
communication regarding these changes
were clear with over 30 000 emails sent
as well as calls to families telling
them that these changes were going to
come upon the new school year reporting
live in the East Valley Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now